j'ai écrit un livre j'ai écrit un livre
qui s'appelle votre cerveau est
extraordinaire et comme je suis
mentaliste je sais déjà qui en a qui se
disent encore un youtuber qui écrit un
livre bon techniquement c'est vrai et
c'est pourquoi dans cette vidéo je vais
vous expliquer ce qu'il ya dans ce livre
pourquoi quand et comment j'ai écrit le
livre comment ça se fait que ce livre
est interactif
hier qu'il communique parfois avec vous
et à la fin je vous parlerai des
historiques qui à l'intérieur il ya des
petites choses des cachets génériques
[Musique]
avant de vous parler des trucs un petit
peu cool qui avec le livre je vais vous
préciser deux trois choses très
rapidement la première chose c'est que
le livre est sorti en france en belgique
en suisse et au québec
amis québécois il sortira que dans trois
semaines chez vous et sinon pour vous le
procurer les disponible partout dans
toutes vos librairies ce qui est génial
parce que ça vous permet aussi de
découvrir les librairies de votre
quartier si vous les connaissez pas et
de voir à quel point les libraires sont
passionnants je vous le recommande
et sinon le trouvait évidemment en
lingala l'action amazon sur tous les
sites je vous mets les liens de tout ça
dans la description pour vous donner un
historique rapide ce projet de livre
gelé depuis plus de trois ans et si vous
faites le calcul j'ai commencé youtube
depuis un peu plus d'un an le projet
initial il était très simple c'est de
mettre les astuces dans un livre et à
l'époque j'en avais référence et 200
astuces mais j'avais pas compris que ça
ferait un gros livre donc au final il y
en a 50 dans celui ci qui sont illustrés
dans une de mes faq de l'année dernière
qu'on n'était pas très nombreux sur la
chaîne j'avais dit que oui j'avais pour
projet d'écrire un livre tu pourrais
sortir un livre sur le mentalisme ça
fait plusieurs fois qu'elle revient
cette question écoute je vais vraiment
te dire j'ai adoré écrire un livre sur
le mentaliste j'aimerais beaucoup faire
ça c'est pas un projet que je déciderai
tout seul dans le sens où il faudrait
une proposition d'un éditeur situé
éditeurs
si vous connaissez un éditeur j'aimerais
beaucoup mettre ce livre en place et
bien suite à ça il ya un jeune homme qui
s'appelle théophile qui a je crois 14 ou
15 ans qui m'avait contacté pour me
donner le contact du père d'un ami et
lui qui travaille dans une maison
d'édition et c'est ce qui a fait que
j'ai rencontré mon éditrice au restart
man des éditions first au mois d'octobre
2016 et qu'on a lancé ce projet au sarc
c'est une saveur particulière j'ai fait
plein de trucs cool tout au long de ma
vie mais avoir un objet quelque chose
qui existe qui se perpétue dans le temps
c'est très spécial surtout quand on sait
que je suis passionné de livres depuis
que je suis petit goût de la lecture je
les tréteaux comme la grande soeur est
allé à la bibliothèque quand j'étais
petit pour faire comme elle j'y allais
aussi je prenais des livres mais j'ai
toujours eu un rapport amical on peut le
dire avec les lip et livres sont donc
mais elle bon c'est pas des amis
brouillon ça c'est sûr j'ai donc
travaillé dessus durant des semaines et
des mois en parallèle déjà de faire une
vidéo par jour
et puis après en parallèle de la tournée
s'est d'ailleurs bientôt la fin de la
tournée je rappelle que la dernière
année à nantes le 30 juin et comme si
vous voulez pas vous en parler non plus
quotidiennement ce qu'il n'y avait pas
d'affairé pour vous que j'ai fait en
sorte quand même que ce soit interactif
dans l'écriture par exemple un jour sur
facebook vous ai demandé de me donner
cinq mots au hasard et en fait c'était
train du ficc je m'étais donné j'ai
pioché un des postes avec cinq mots au
hasard et je les aient calé dans un
chapitre comme étant une contrainte les
cinq mots c'était collage dans ce génie
tristesse et rousset a calé dans le
chapitre influencer un show avec des
mots après j'ai vraiment fini
créature dans les chambres d'hôtel dans
les loges au théâtre dans les trains
avec gary seraient diable other genre
faisait les gars me disais si c'était
bien pas bien s'il comprenait ou pas en
fait diable aux heures des fois il
comprend n'est pas alors on a rajouté
des dessins et je voulais surtout pas
écrire un livre genre d'ovni mentalist
parce que c'est pas ça l'objet des trucs
la vérité c'est que vous et votre
cerveau vous êtes déjà capable de plein
de choses on l'a vu depuis plus d'un an
il ya 400 vidéos sur cette chaîne est
bien l'idée c'était de synthétiser tout
ça est fermée avec ça alors quand
j'étais plus jeune il y avait un livre
qui me passionnait c'était le manuel des
castors juniors bim la référence j'ai
voulu recréer la même chose d'une
manière plus adulte évidemment mais là
derrière ça donne ça avec un effet un
peu cahiers et c'est pêle-mêle tout est
un petit peu mélangés mais en réalité
j'ai mélangé sept grands thèmes qu'il ya
un index des thèmes à la fin de toute
manière pour se retrouver dans les
thèmes il ya hypnose et suggestions on
va dire tout ce qui concerne les
influences il ya aussi le grand thème de
la théorie théorie on est bien sûr qu'on
en filière de la théorie a que trois
chapitres me sont essentielles pas mal
de chapitres sur le développement de la
mémoire pas mal de chapitres le
développement du calcul mental
un grand nombre de chapitres sur la
lecture non verbale et la déduction du
coût une dizaine de chapitres sur des
expériences bluffante que vous pouvez
reproduire c'est ce qu'on appelle les
tours c'est ce que je fais des fois
quand je bluffe quelqu'un sur la chaîne
et une partie qu'on savait pas trop
comment à clé on va l'appeler de la
partie de développement personnel oh non
c'est pas la méditation c'est plutôt sur
les rêves lucides sur la créativité sur
la motivation pour le fait de réussir un
examen oral tout ce genre de choses qui
étaient un petit peu inclassable
au final c'est construit comme un
triangle c'est à dire que si vous
connaissez ce que je fais sur youtube où
ce que je fais en spectacle c'est la
troisième pointe du triangle et tous
associe j'ai essayé de garder même ton
le même style quand je suis en spectacle
on discute ensemble dont se parent
ensemble durant 1h40 quand je suis dans
les vidéos on échange réellement que ce
soit dans la vidéo dans les commentaires
ou via les énigmes que j'avais mis en
place il ya toujours un moyen de se
retrouver le livre c'était plus
compliqué j'ai trouvé quelques id le
livre est interactif parfois le livre à
anticiper certaines de vos réactions à
la lecture et j'espère que ça vous fera
marrer et à trois occasions le livre en
lui-même va vous permettre de bluffer
quelqu'un vous raconter une anecdote
très courte mon éditrice elle m'a dit
est ce que tu veux des rabats ou pas
pour le livre si bas ça sert à quoi
concrètement les rabats aujourd'hui ça
sert plus à grand-chose concrètement on
peut écrire des trucs dessus ça peut
servir marque pages on me mettre des
choses à l'intérieur
et voilà c'est un choix et là je me suis
dit mais attend on peut en faire quelque
chose donc j'ai créé un chapitre où le
livre et les rabats du livre vont vous
permettre de bluffer quelqu'un une sorte
de triangle que vous avez posé entre
vous et quelqu'un la personne va devoir
choisir un symbolisme se concentrer sur
le deuxième rabat et vous allez devinez
quel symbole elle avait pensé il ya
d'autre chose de caché comme ça qu'ils
rendent encore le lit
interactif mais il ya aussi des choses
qui sont réellement caché qu'ils sont
presque plus destiné à vous à d'autres
personnes chacun peut trouver des choses
non scié par exemple dans un endroit du
lit faut que je prenne des noms au
hasard et je parle de trois personnes le
pierre de lola et de william n'est pas
un hasard pas plus que le fait qu'il
soit dans cet ordre là précisément on va
dit vous qu'il ya pas de hasard dans le
livre sauf un il ya une coquille
il ya une coquille sur une date vous la
trouverez je pense que vous la trouverez
vous pourrez me le dire dans les
commentaires qu'on vous le rétrograder
dédicaces qui s'organiseront je vous le
dirai sur twitter sur facebook
instagram est sûre snapo si vous voulez
être tenu au courant sont gratuites et
là dessus il ya les biens dans la
description et si vous êtes encore là je
vous dis un secret je suis allé dans
quelques librairies et quelques snacks
et j'ai signé les livres les et dédicacé
c'est à dire que si vous trouvez quelque
part un livre avec une dédicace à
l'intérieur c'est une vraie dédicaces ça
m'a fait rire de faire ça j'ai fait ça
en l'achetant moi même le livre à la
fnac le jour de sa sortie et ses livres
la gelée ensuite offert dans la rue à la
première personne qui est venu me dire
bonjour voilà j'espère qu'une seule
chose maintenant c'est qu'il vous plaira
et qui vous servira vous savez j'ai bien
conscience d'un truc on était à peu près
50 mx 60 milles sur la chaîne quand ça
s'est concrétisé le projet et je sais
pertinemment j'ai conscience que c'est
parce que vous me suivez sur la chaîne
qu'ils ont accepté plus facilement ce
projet la réalisation de ce rêve et la
sortie de ce livre je vous le dois alors
merci beaucoup merci à vous lorsque vous
le dire et n'oubliez pas une chose
essentielle pour que l'une de ces
cinquante astuce fonctionne il suffit de
vous en servir
merci à vous et à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]